hey 42 here politics is a strange thing
it can switch in an instant from dollars
to disaster from inspiring to insanity
and from dinner table chats he's
fighting in the streets and what's with
the problem groove is that when you
align yourself with one particular group
you feel obliged to stick up for them
for better or for worse leading to
arguments so what about the few
politicians that we could actually agree
on seems like an impossible task
doesn't it surely such a rare creature
doesn't even exist in the wild well
you're in for a big surprise
because here are five politicians that
everyone will look first we head to
Canada was not for the lustrous hair of
Justin Trudeau the rhinoceros party was
set up in 1963 by Jack Sparrow
a physician and author it was intended
as political satire and it kept going
for 30 years in a refreshing display of
honestly their Creed was a promise to
keep none of their promises they listed
their leader as an actual rhinoceros
from a Montreal Zoo called Cornelius the
first since you need a fix skin to be a
leader leaders also claimed to be
Marxist Leninist but rather than having
any communist ideals it was just because
they were fans of GU Cho Marx and John
Lennon over the years some of their
brilliant party policies have included
changing Canada's currency to bubblegum
so it can be inflated or deflated at
will repealing the law of gravity and
providing higher education by building
taller schools although they never want
a single seat they did occasionally
embarrass authentic political parties
such as when Sonia a professional clown
came in second for one of the seats in
1980 the party was forced to disband in
1993 due to a change in the law that
would force them to run for Italy 50
seats at the cost of a thousand dollars
a seat that's far too pricey for a good
old political jest in the same year that
the rhinoceros party was founded as
similarly satirical approaches being
adopted in the UK by
singer David search in 1963 he
represented a range of different major
parties in the parliamentary election
most notably the National teenage party
since about time the voting age is 21
which suits disagrees with his bands
screaming Lord Sutch and the savages
were not especially successful but their
lineup was constantly changing and they
had many of rock's
superstars before they became famous
including Jimmy Page of Led Zeppelin
Ritchie Blackmore deep purple unknown
reading which was Jimi Hendrix's bass
player such returns to politics in the
80s after leaving America when he was
shot during the mugging a fairly solid
sign that you don't belong someone he
set up the now infamous monster raving
loony party and was joined by others
including the retired World War two hero
named build boats who had been part of
the sinking of the Bismarck although
they never won any seat in parliament
they did take a number of counsel spots
in Devon where they spent a lot of time
trying to annoy the conservative with
one loony party councillor attempting to
pay some taxes with a pile of metal was
across the country they established
themselves as one of the leading protest
boat groups for many many years
such sadly committed suicide in 1999 but
as was fitting for his party they
elected Alan Howland Lord hope and his
caps cap mundo to take over the
leadership their party policies include
putting a massive mirror into the sky to
reflect the sunlight during the night
time so that solar panels still work
introducing a 99 pence coin to make it
easier to buy ice cream and bungee cords
shall be attached to the rear of all
cars so that no fuel is used on the
return journey when Donald Trump
announced that Linda McMackin the
co-founder of wrestling franchise WWE
would be a part of his new government a
group of Mexicans actually deserve the
credit for their groundbreaking work 20
years earlier in 1996 a wrestler named
Super Mario ran for president of the
United States and arranged rallies on
both sides of the Mexican border
promising to do away with border patrol
I'm the Drug Enforcement Agency although
he dressed in a resin yellow lucha
wrestling outfit super mario was a true
political activist rather than just a
comedy figure unfortunately his attempt
to wrestle his way into the political
ranks were unsuccessful dick Agustin is
a Swedish IT entrepreneur who when grew
tired of endless jokes about his first
name decided to change the whole thing
and become Rick Fox bombs or Falcon
wings as it's translated through his
love of technology it was part of the
early file-sharing community so when the
internet copyright debate began to
pickled internationally in 2005 he
decided to get involved by setting up
the Pirate Party his domain got three
million hits in the first two days but
he wasn't just casually dipping his toe
into politics he quit his job took out a
large bank loan and really put his heart
and soul into the party within a year he
made the international news as a voice
criticizing the raid on the Pirate Bay
a famous file-sharing site based in
Sweden so in a way I'm telling you that
he you know what the Pirate Bay he only
managed 0.63 percent of the vote in 2006
but by the time the European elections
came around he 2009 he won a massive
majority of the youth vote taking 25% of
those on the 30 and over 7% overall he's
been recognized around the world as a
key figure in bringing the Internet into
politics well before we started electing
people on the basis of their emails and
Twitter the good old days now if you're
going to elect a bad-tempered a prove no
idea what it's doing Brazil at least
decided to go through an actual
chimpanzee pl the chimp was estimated to
have received a massive 400,000 votes in
the 1988 election for mayor of Rio de
Janeiro
he came third out of 12 candidates or to
put it another way nine actual human
politicians were beaten by a monkey the
chimp eventually died of diabetes
because as the saying goes in Brazil
with great power comes a great amount of
sure
thanks for watching if we go back to the
Middle Ages or even all the way back to
the Roman Empire was life ever any
better then you could be an
extraordinarily intelligent person
possibly even genius level